You've heard it in the news before, right?
Genetically modified organisms?
Are they safe?
Or are they unsafe?
In the United States and Western Europe, many people choose to buy groceries at food
co-ops that don't carry genetically modified products or GMOs for short, and they'll spend
extra money just to avoid it.
Also, these consumers might avoid milk from cows treated with growth hormone and fruits
and vegetables produced using genetic techniques.
In addition to exercising their rights at the grocery store, many protest against GMOs,
and they work towards legislation that'll prevent those foods from entering the marketplace.
And they want to make sure that GMOs are clearly labeled on their packages.
Do these people have any real science to back up their claims?
Or is it all just hearsay and rumors and basing their ideas on what they see on the internet
from certain groups?
Are their actions and voices hurting more than just their own bank account?
Are objections to genetic modified foods affecting impoverished people who actually don't have
a voice in the debate?
But much more to lose their lives and suffering from starvation, for example.
Take for example golden rice, a genetically modified rice that could help prevent deficiencies
in vitamin A that cause serious health issues for our poorest people on the planet.
This rice appears golden because it's rich in beta-carotene, which is necessary for the
synthesis of vitamin A.
According to the World Health Organization and UNICEF, 40% of children under the age
of five in the developing world are deficient in vitamin A.
It also compromises their immune system and leads to high death rates and even blindness.
Half a million children go blind every year.
Although scientific and regulatory agencies around the world have repeatedly and consistently
found modified foods to be safe, anti-GMO organizations like Greenpeace have worked to
slow the development and distribution of foods, including golden rice.
Should people in developed countries with access to a stable food supply be able to
prevent technologies that could help millions of impoverished people when no science actually
backs their claims?
To better understand the debate about this and many other genetic technologies, we'll
take a look at how and why these technologies are being used, as well as other potential
ethical issues that they raise.
We'll also learn about gene expression, mutation, stem cells, and cloning in this chapter.
Some questions to ask ourselves as we go through this, considering food justice and equity.
Do objections to genetically modified foods adversely affect impoverished people who
have fewer resources and less influence on government policies?
And another question, are genetically modified foods produced for profits or for humanitarian
efforts?
As we go through our chapter, be sure to identify these learning outcomes as you reach them
and review them often in your notes, lecture, and in the book.
Once again, golden rice.
It's a genetically modified organism and it looks golden because it's so rich in beta
keratin, which is very, very essential for vitamin A synthesis, as we said before, vitamin
A deficiencies are found in 40% of this world's children.
Vitamin A deficiencies definitely lead to health problems, as we see in the young man
in the upper corner.
For instance, compromised immune system, childhood blindness even, over 500,000 children go blind
each year and about 50% will die within one year of going blind.
Here's a question.
See if you know this.
For how many years have genetically modified crops been available in our foods?
So our answer here is 20.
Although a slower method of genetically modifying our food has been around for thousands of years,
and that's called artificial selection, but we'll get to that eventually.
So in order to produce GMOs or genetically modified organisms, we have to regulate gene
expression.
Regulating gene expression is controlling the amount of proteins that an organism produces.
All living organisms have the ability to regulate gene expression.
And bacteria can do this in response to the changes in their environment.
And that allows a particular gene to increase or decrease the amount of protein produced
to meet the changing demands of the cell without wasting a lot of energy or making more protein
than what would be needed.
Scientists have figured out how to transfer the regulating of gene expression over to
the science lab.
One of the first examples of scientists controlling gene expression occurred in the early 1980s
when genetic engineers began to produce recombinant bovine growth hormone, or RBGH for short.
This was done in their laboratories.
Recombinant bovine growth hormone, or R, means the recombinant, it's a protein that's made
by genetically engineered bacteria.
These bacteria cells have had their DNA manipulated, so it carries the instructions for or encodes
a cow growth protein that can be produced in the laboratory.
Growth hormones act on many different organs to increase the overhaul size of the body.
Bovine growth hormone that's produced in a laboratory can be ejected into dairy cows
to increase their milk production which then of course would feed more people.
Production of growth hormone protein or any protein in the lab or in a cell requires the
use of genetic information coded in the DNA.
Protein synthesis involves the using of instructions carried by a gene to build a particular protein.
Remember that a gene is a sequence of DNA that codes for a protein.
When you're looking at someone you're actually looking at proteins or the results of proteins.
A protein is a very large molecule, a macromolecule composed of building blocks called amino acids.
There's about 20 different amino acids in the human body and in living organisms that
compose all the proteins that make us.
The actual genes themselves built into DNA do not build proteins directly, instead you
could say they carry the instructions or the recipe that dictates how a protein should
be built.
Understanding protein synthesis requires that we review a first, a few basic things about
DNA genes and RNA.
First of all remember that DNA, a very big macromolecule is a polymer and a polymer means
that it's a molecule built out of repeating units.
The repeating unit that builds DNA is called nucleotides.
You can see a picture of a nucleotide here off to the right.
This is the nucleotide thymine, a nucleotide contains the base unit, in this case it's
thymine but it could also be adenine, cytosine or guanine, if it's DNA.
In RNA there's another type of nucleotide called uracil.
You'll notice that the base unit has hydrogens, carbons, oxygens and then nitrogens, so sometimes
they're nicknamed nitrogen bases.
Another part of a nucleotide is the sugar, it's a small simple sugar that forms a pentagon
when in a water solution like the water in our body.
It's called deoxyribose, if this was RNA it would be just ribose.
And then third, a nucleotide is made out of a phosphate group which formula is PO4.
The phosphate group has a negative charge which gives DNA overall a negative charge,
which makes it very useful in DNA fingerprinting.
You can send it through electrically charged gel and it'll travel towards the opposite
charged end, the positive end.
Again, there's four different bases that comprise DNA, thymine, adenine, cytosine and
guanine.
Remember that DNA is actually a double helix as we see in the picture here to the right,
it's a twisted ladder.
So there's two sides and remember the complementary pairing, that adenine always pairs with thymine
and cytosine always pairs with guanine.
So we see that here in the top picture, cytosine with guanines, thymine with adenines.
That way you only have to figure out one side of DNA and you'll know the other because
of the complementary base pairing.
RNA is a very related molecule, there's a few different types of RNA, the one we're
looking at here is called messenger RNA.
RNA is just single stranded but it's also made out of nucleotides, it's made out of some
of the same ones as DNA but there is one different one.
There is adenine, cytosine and guanine but instead of thymine in RNA you will find uracil
which actually in reality looks very similar to thymine anyway.
So again RNA is a polymer of nucleotides just like DNA except that it's single stranded
in this case, that's made out of nucleotides which have the same parts, the base, the sugar
in this case it's ribose and then the phosphate group as well.
RNA's job is to come in and make a copy of genes on DNA.
So when the copying happens, cytosine will pair with guanine as usual but adenine must
pair with uracil because RNA does not have any thymine.
So protein synthesis goes in many steps from DNA from the actual gene to the RNA or mRNA
messenger RNA for short which copies those genes with a complementary copy and then it
takes that message out to where the proteins are actually built in the cytoplasm at the
ribosomes which actually is also made out of RNA as well but it's more like clumps
of RNA.
So the flow of genetic information goes through those steps.
Transcription is going from DNA to RNA and translation is going from RNA to protein.
So here's an example of that here, we've got our double stranded DNA laid out flat so
we're looking at a portion of a gene here, we can see our nucleotides lined up with their
complementary base pairs, A's with T's, C's with G's, RNA must come in and copy the coding
strand of the DNA, looks like it's this top one here and it makes a complementary copy.
So if DNA said C RNA would put down a G then our next letter in DNA is a G so RNA puts down
a C. DNA has a T next so RNA then would match up with an A and then when DNA has an A RNA
would match up with a U and so on and so forth until the whole gene is copied or transcribed.
This is again a single strand which makes it nice and skinny enough to fit through the
nucleus pores and then travel out to the ribosome which is in the cytoplasm and then the protein
is actually built by another type of RNA that we'll get to in a moment called T RNA or transfer
RNA that will bring these amino acids in the correct order and then the ribosome will
help chain those together until we make our protein.
So once again transcription is going from DNA to RNA it occurs in the nucleus of the cell
and this forms the type of RNA called mRNA or messenger RNA. An enzyme that big green
thing here is called RNA polymerase. It binds to what's called a promoter it's a sequence
of DNA that lets the RNA polymerase know where to actually bind where that gene actually
starts once it binds to DNA it unzips it temporarily and then starts adding these mRNA nucleotides.
Remember the correct pairing? If DNA says A RNA says U if DNA says T RNA says A if DNA
says C RNA says G if DNA says C and I do that one already if DNA says G RNA says C I hope
I got all four in there. So it lays down these complementary nucleotides and it just copies
the gene not the whole sequence of DNA just the gene. So again the promoter is the sequence
of DNA where it binds unzips the DNA and then we lay down our RNA nucleotides and then that
will leave so that DNA can zip back up again as if nothing happens.
Now our mRNA can travel out to the ribosome which is out in the cytoplasm usually attached
to the endoplasmic reticulum but some ribosomes do float freely in the cytoplasm and we're
going to put together our protein here that's called translation. So our requirements we
need to have made a correct copy of mRNA during transcription so that should be a complementary
copy of the gene from DNA. We're going to need amino acids you get those through your
diet and through cells making them those will be floating around in the cytoplasm they'll
be also attached to tRNA molecules transfer RNA for short or tRNA for short because they
bring the amino acids to the correct location. We'll need ribosomes which are made out of
clumps of RNA called ribosomal or rRNA and then of course as most things need we need
energy in the form of ATP to do this as well. Here's what a ribosome looks like it looks
like two big clumps. It's made out of RNA that's kind of folded to look like clumps
like this so it's still made out of nucleotides A, C's, G's and U's but it's all folded up
to make these clumps. There's a large subunit and a small subunit so this type of RNA is
called rRNA or ribosomal RNA. Here's the transfer RNA or tRNA for short. It's kind of
shaped like a quover leaf some books call it a quover leaf although I don't know that
it looks like a quover leaf to me looks more like a cross. The bottom part of the tRNA has
a code it's called an anti codon so it's a sequence of three nucleotides that are going
to match up with a sequence of three nucleotides on mRNA called the codon. Over on the other
end here we have the amino acid attached so this is called the transfer RNA because it
grabs on to specific amino acids in the cytoplasm and brings them to the ribosomal RNA or ribosome.
Again remember the sequence of three nucleotides on mRNA is called a codon. Remember that was
originally complimentary copied from DNA in the nucleus and then we have the anti codon
the three nucleotides on the tRNA so you can see how it's very specific how they match
up and how they bring only specific amino acids in a certain order based on the order
of nucleotides of mRNA which was originally copied from DNA. So protein synthesis is similar
to baking a cake. We have our genome or genes in the nucleus then we make a copy of mRNA
of that gene whatever protein we need that's the gene we're going to copy. Remember it's
a complimentary copy though. Then we go to the ribosome out in the cytoplasm the ribosome
locks on to the mRNA. It also grabs the tRNA as well and matches them up so that the proper
amino acids are brought and then we make our protein. Which type of RNA carries amino acids
to the growing polypeptide chain? That would be tRNA. A polypeptide chain is what a protein
is called before it's finished. So proteins are made by attaching one amino acid at a time
in a chain because proteins just like DNA are also a polymer made out of different repeating
units called amino acids. Although DNA has just four building blocks proteins have about
20 building blocks called amino acids that we find in ourselves. The ribosome attaches
to the mRNA at the promoter region then the ribosome facilitates the docking of tRNA
anti codons to the mRNA codons. A peptide bond that's one that forms between amino acids
will join the two adjacent tRNAs. A stop codon when a ribosome reaches that that's a codon
that doesn't code for any amino acids. That's when the ribosome knows the protein is done
and to release it. So it looks like this. This big purple thing that is our ribosome
and look how it's reading the mRNA just three letters at a time. Three letters here, UUU
is the codon that matches up with the anti codon on tRNA which then would be AAAA. And
then that particular tRNA brings in amino acid called phenylalanine and joins it to the
chain. And then the next one will be red. mRNA is codons as AUA. So the tRNA anti codon
will say UAU and will bring this particular amino acid. And we keep chaining these amino
acids together until we reach a stop codon which doesn't code for anything. And so then
the ribosome knows to let that protein go. Once tRNAs deliver an amino acid to the ribosome,
they're free to leave and go pick up more amino acids. And in this way we're able to
build proteins. So our genetic code is the order of DNA nucleotides. It allows a specific
codon to code for a specific amino acid. So a codon again is composed of three nucleotides
so I like to call it a triplet. So there's four to the three possible combinations. There's
61 different codons that code for amino acids along with three that are stop codons which
actually end protein synthesis. The genetic code is actually redundant because there's
multiple codons that can code for the same amino acid like for instance these four codons
all code for the same amino acid three and the genetic code is universal. For instance
UUU that codon on mRNA codes for phenylalanine and nothing else. And all organisms decode
the same gene to produce the same protein. We all have that in common. Pretty cool.
Here's the chart that scientists use to look up amino acids and they figured this out in
a certain year. I can't quite remember which year that was but this is the chart that we
all use now and it comes in a few different forms but this is the one that your book uses.
For instance let's use the UUU for phenylalanine. We take the first base look it up here U and
then we take the next base second base U. We know it's going to be in this box and then
we bring the third base over third base right here U. Bring it over UUU then we code for
phenylalanine but you'll also see there's another codon that also codes for phenylalanine
UUC also does. Instead of writing the whole amino acid down scientists often only write
the first three letters it helps to shorten it up a little bit so instead of writing phenylalanine
they'll write PHE for short. Here's the three stop codons UAA, UAG and UGA. They don't code
for anything they tell the ribosome the protein is done. Here's the start codon methionine
all polypeptide chains are proteins start with methionine. A sequence of mRNA called
a codon reads GGA. What sequence of nucleotides will be on the anti codon on the tRNA? Well
remember the complementary base pairs what pairs with G? Well that would be C. So CC
and what pairs with A? That would be U. So CCU is the correct answer and let's go ahead
and look up what amino acid that would be coding for. Scientists use the mRNA codon to
look it up even though the tRNA is the one that carries it to the ribosome. Scientists
use the mRNA to look it up. So we're going to look up GGA back here at our chart. Our
first base is G. Second base here is G. So it's going to be in this box. Third base is
A. So bring it over GGA is going to code for an amino acid called glutamic acid or GLU
for short. So in eukaryotic cells those that have a nucleus protein synthesis is spatially
separated with where transcription occurs which is in the nucleus and where translation
occurs which is outside the nucleus. But in prokaryotic cells they don't have a nucleus
so transcription and translation would have to occur at the same time and the same place
as we see here in the bacteria or prokaryotic cell here below. We've got DNA and transcription
happening very close to where the actual translation is happening at the ribosome. Sometimes
mistakes are made. These are called mutations. It's a change in the genetic sequence like
for instance one letter being missing or one letter being changed to something else or
more than one letter being changed. Of course this then can affect well the sequence so
then that can affect the order of the amino acids and the protein. So the precise order
of amino acids is very necessary for properly functioning proteins. Although not all mutations
are bad, yes some mutations will result in a non-functional protein but some might result
in no change in the protein because well if it's a change that's really close to what
we had such as if it was a codon that used to be UUA and now A got changed to a G for
the codon in mRNA. You'll see that codes for the same amino acid anyway so your cells
wouldn't even notice that one because you would still code for leucine but if you went
from a UUA to a UUU well that would change our amino acid from leucine to phenylalanine
and phenylalanine might have different properties than leucine and it might change up how the
protein works and it might make it a non-functional protein or it might even make the protein work
better make it a different protein that has happened as well. So lots of different outcomes
here from no change that's a neutral mutation to a non-functional protein to a just a different
protein that functions in a different maybe even better way.
So here's some examples this is a substitution mutation where one simple substitution of a
base is for another. So here in our DNA we had CTA and then the mRNA codon for that would
be GAU so CTA I'm using this top strand is my coding strand CTA to GAU and then that
would code for this amino acid here called asparginine well what happens instead of CTA
what if it becomes CCA and we substitute a C for the T that used to be there will that
change our codon on our mRNA yes it will our new codon will read GGU and if I go back to
my amino acid chart GGU codes for glycine there it is there so we have changed our amino acid
from asparginine to glycine and this could potentially be a non-functional protein we
can see it's shaped differently than the original one a neutral mutation does not change the
function of the protein as we've seen before the same amino acid can result from the codon
as we see here again our T got changed to a C but in this case it didn't matter it codes
for the same amino acid so nothing changed here this was a neutral mutation this one's
a little more abrupt this is a frame shift mutation sometimes a base gets added or deleted
out of DNA sequence this changes the reading frame by if a base is added it pushes it down
or if a base is deleted then it pushes the other bases over it changes the reading frame
hence frame shift mutation in the name sometimes can result in a stop codon or a shorter non-functional
protein might be produced what type of mutation will result in the production of a regular
protein that would be a neutral mutation each body cell except sperm and eggs of course
because they have half each body cell or somatic cell has the same DNA and humans that would
be a DNA for 46 chromosomes and cells express different genes based on their functions so
it means that some genes are actually turned off in certain cells and turned on in others
so genetic engineering precisely controls gene expression the first step in the production
of the R B G H protein is to transfer the B G H gene from the nucleus of a cow cell into
the bacterial cell bacteria are single celled prokaryotes that copy themselves very rapidly
after all their single circular chromosome in their cytoplasm only contains maybe a few
million base pairs they can thrive in the laboratory if they're allowed to grow in a
liquid broth containing the nutrients they need for life bacteria with the B G H gene
can serve as factories to produce millions of copies of this gene and its protein product
making many copies of a gene is called cloning a gene here's the following steps involved
in moving a B G H gene into a bacteria cell first of all we have to remove the gene from
the cow chromosome the gene is sliced out of the cow chromosome on which it resides by
exposing the cow DNA to enzymes that cut the DNA enzymes that cut DNA are called restriction
enzymes they act like highly specific molecular scissors most restriction enzymes cut DNA
only at a specific sequence called a palindrome note that the bottom middle sequence is the
reverse of the top middle sequence many restriction enzymes cut the DNA in a staggered pattern
leaving what's called sticky ends the unpaired bases form bonds with any complementary bases
with which they come in contact with the enzyme selected by scientists cuts on both ends of
the B H gene but not inside the gene a particular restriction enzyme cuts DNA at a specific
sequence therefore scientists need information about the organisms genome in order to determine
which restriction enzyme cutting sites surround the gene of interest cutting the DNA generates
many different fragments only one of which will carry the gene of interest for step 2
we have to insert the B G H gene into the bacterial plasmid a plasmid is a small circular piece
of DNA so once the gene is removed from the cow genome it's inserted into a bacterial
structure called a plasmid a plasmid is a circular piece of DNA that normally exists
separate from the bacterial chromosome and can replicate independently of the main bacterial
chromosome think of the plasmid as a molecular fairy boat able to carry a gene into a bacterial
cell where it can be replicated to incorporate the B G H gene into the plasmid the plasmid
is also cut with the same restriction enzyme used to cut the main gene cutting both the
plasmid and the gene with the same enzyme allows the sticky ends that are generated
to base pair with each other remember A's always with T's and C's always with G's
when the cut plasmid and the cut gene are placed together in a test tube they'll reform
back together into a circular plasmid with the extra gene now incorporated and here we
can see it here in the picture
the bacterial plasmid has now been genetically engineered to carry a cow gene at this juncture
the B G H gene is referred to as the RB G H gene with the R indicated that this product
is genetically engineered or recombinant because it's been removed from the original location
in the cow genome and recombined there's the word recombined with the plasmid DNA
next we have to insert the recombinant plasmid into a bacterial cell the recombinant plasmid
is now inserted into a bacterial cell and the bacteria can be treated so their cell membranes
become porous when treated bacteria are placed into a suspension of plasmids the bacterial
cells allow the plasmids back into their cytoplasm of their cell once inside the cell the plasmids
replicate themselves as does the bacteria cell making thousands of copies of our gene
so using this procedure scientists can grow large amounts of bacteria capable of producing
B G H once scientists successfully clone the B G H gene into bacteria cells the bacteria
produce the protein encoded by the gene then the scientists are able to break open the
bacteria cells isolate the B G H protein and inject it in the cows bacteria can be genetically
engineered to produce many proteins of importance for humans for example bacteria are now used
to produce the clotting protein missing from people with hemophilia as well as human insulation
for people or insulin for people with diabetes the FDA or food and drug administration regulates
this the majority of US dairy cows receive daily RB G H injections and the injected cows
will have 20% more milk than those without it the FDA ensures safety of food and food
ingredients so there's no detectable difference between milk from treated and untreated cows
there is literally no way to distinguish RB G H milk from non RB G H milk the RB G H story
is a little different from that of most GMOs because RB G H protein is produced by bacteria
and then administered to cows when organisms are genetically modified the genome itself
is altered so we'll see this in the next sections according to the FDA what differences
are found in milk from cows treated with RB G H versus milk from untreated cows remember
there's actually no detectable difference between these two types of milk unless you've
been making a concerted effort not to you've been consuming genetically modified foods every
day for the past 20 years the majority of the corn and soy grown in the United States
has been genetically modified in fact as we see from the graph GMO foods or GM foods have
increased the production over the past 20 years since 1996 from a low percentage to a
very high percentage
process foods come from GM products like corn syrup which we find in a lot of the foods
and sweets and things that we eat like this great flavored drink here also found in soy
and vegetable oils for some this causes concern let's see if we can figure out why and if there's
any scientific reason why there should be any concern first of all a form of genetically
modifying organisms as food and foods has been occurring for over thousands of years actually
both plants and animals have been subject to human modification by what's called artificial
selection for thousands of years every time a farmer chooses which plants or animals to
use in producing for the next generation he or she is modifying the frequency of alleles
in that population of organisms by artificial selection in fact golden rice was first produced
using artificial selection scientists switch to using the available genetic technologies
when artificial selection techniques were only able to establish strains with slightly
higher than normal beta carotene levels over many generations golden rice can be engineered
to contain more than 20 times the amount of beta carotene in just one generation although
crossing plants to increase nutritive value or breeding those cattle that produce more
milk does not involve moving a gene from one organism to another it does select for the
propagation of particular genes in addition to increasing the rate at which a desirable
trait can be produced the suite of genes available for use is also increased to the use of genetic
technologies for instance two corn plants that are bred together can only draw from traits
coded by genes contained in their genomes I'll go back to this slide with genetic engineering
genes from other organisms can be introduced into the genome it's this slicing of genes
from unrelated organisms that is the source of the most concern about modifying foods to
understand whether these concerns are justified we must first consider how crops are modified
to move a novel gene into a plant a gene must be able to gain access to the plant cell which
means it must be able to move through the plants rigid cell wall moving genes into many
agricultural crops like corn barley and rice can be accomplished using a device called a
gene gun a gene gun shoots DNA coated pellets into a plant cell a small percentage of these
genes may be incorporated into the plant's genome then when a gene from one species is
incorporated into the genome of another it's called the transgenic organism when the embryonic
plant so treated grows into an adult plant all of its cells contain the inserted gene and the
gene will be passed on to its offspring crop plants are genetically modified to increase their
shelf life for one reason tomatoes for instance have been engineered to soften and ripen more
slowly the longer ripening time means that tomatoes stay on the vine longer thus making
them taste better the slower ripening also increases the amount of time that tomatoes will
be appealing to its consumers who don't want to purchase fruit that's over ripe or bruised
genetic engineering techniques also increase crop yield when plants are manipulated to be
resistant to pesticides and herbicides for centuries farmers have tried to increase yields by killing
the pests that damage their crops by controlling the growth of weeds that compete for the nutrients
water and sunlight in the u.s. farmers typically spray high volumes of chemical pesticides and
herbicides directly onto their fields this practice concerns people worried about the
health effects of eating food that's been treated by often toxic and cancer c-cancer
causing chemicals in addition both pesticides and herbicides may leech through the soil
and contaminate drinking water there is hope and even some evidence that plants modified
to be resistant herbicides and pesticides would allow farmers to use less chemicals so that's good
news another concern is that genetically modified crop plants may transfer engineered genes from
modified cramp crop plants to their wild or weedy relatives when rain birds and bees carry
genetically modified pollen to related plants in nearby fields containing genetically or
non genetically modified crops many cultivated crops have retained the ability to interbreed
with their wild relatives in these cases genes from farm crops can mix with genes from wild
crops and with crops grown in nearby farms including those that are meant to be organic
and thus free of GMO products animals can be genetically modified as well
Alaskan salmon have been engineered to carry genes from other fish that make them grow
larger and faster than normal eggs from wild Alaskan salmon are injected with the gene that
codes for growth hormone from other faster growing fish because this gene is injected
into the fertilized egg cell all the cells of the grown salmon would then express this
enhanced version of growth factor these then would be called transgenic salmon the benefits
the salmon can eat less food but grow twice as fast they can be grown in isolation by
cities there's a reduced transportation cost and it prevents interbreeding with wild fish
some concerns though engineered salmon mating can happen with salmon in the wild populations
also these transgenic salmon could also increase competition with organisms around them and
can disrupt food webs it remains to be seen whether consumers will notice any difference
in the taste of modified salmon compared with the unmodified versions that they're used to
eating why were genetically or why were salmon genetically modified letter D to increase their
growth rate using less food in addition to being genetically modified for human dietary
consumption animals can be modified to help humans in other ways biological farming a
blend of the words pharmaceutical and farming biological farming is the production of GMOs
that produce drugs used to treat or prevent disease tobacco plants have been engineered
to produce proteins normally found in human blood goats have been engineered to produce
human blood clotting proteins in their milk concerns about farming include the ethics of
using animals in this manner and the unregulated spread of modified plant or animal genes via
reproduction here in the picture we see a human clotting gene being injected into a fertilized
bag then the female goats pregnant and then the offspring goat goat is being milked with
the proteins being in the goat's milk instead of combining genes from species that would
never mate in nature to produce transgenic organisms scientists have recently discovered
a way to directly alter delete and even replace a DNA sequence in an organism the powerful
new tool scientists are using for a gene editing process is known as CRISPR it stands for clustered
regularly interspace palindromic repeats widespread application of this technology which is faster
more effective and less cumbersome than its predecessor techniques will allow precise
modification of crop plants and animals to delete mutations and to add desired gene sequences
CRISPR is a naturally occurring part of a bacterias immune system its evolution allowed bacteria
to thwart a viral infection by removing genetic information present in an invading virus scientists
have co-opted this bacterial system for use in other organisms there are two components
in the CRISPR system first the first component is a guide that finds the DNA sequence it has
been sent to edit and the second the second is an enzyme that functions like a molecular
scissors to snip out the unwanted DNA and replace it with the corrected DNA sequence
are experimenting with the use of this technique to delete genes that attract pests in crop
plants decreasing the use of pesticides in addition crops may someday be modified to stay
fresh longer or to contain more nutrients or fiber alterations to animals are on the
horizon as well livestock breeders may be able to use CRISPR to produce animals with
more muscle mass and more leaner meat scientists are even attempting to edit genes and pig
embryos to make their organs suitable for transplantation to humans perhaps the most
exciting use of CRISPR is the ability to edit genes involved in reproduction in the mosquito
that causes malaria leading to the eradication of the species of mosquito this would prevent
the deaths of close to 1 million African people a year 70% whom our children like the one pictured
to the right so we've discussed genetically modifying crop plants and other organisms
but how about humans not surprisingly genetic modification of humans has been even more controversial
than modification of other living things from the use of stem cells to cloning of humans
the potential risks and benefits are still emerging stem cells are unspecialized or undifferentiated
precursor cells with an undetermined function they can become whatever they want they typically
have all of their genes turned on nothing's been turned off yet so they can become whatever
and that's the case of like in a zygote after fertilization after the egg divides by mitosis
becomes this ball of cells called a zygote these are all stem cells that have a capacity
to become anything from nerve cells to heart cells to liver cells to skin cells as embryos
develop then the cells become more specialized that's because different genes get turned
off and on within those cells it's like they get their specialized assignment of what they
become and then they're unable to turn back and become anything else when they're specialized
they are now non stem cells and can only make copies of those cell types scientists believe
that stem cells when nudged in a particular direction can become any type of cell and
therefore can serve as this type of all-purpose repair material for the body stem cells can
be isolated from early embryos that are left over after fertility treatments in vitro which
in latin means in glass in vitro fertilization procedures often result in the production of
excess embryos because many egg cells are harvested from a woman who wishes to become
pregnant the egg cells are then mixed with their partner sperm in a petri dish often
resulting in the production of many fertilized eggs that can grow into embryos a few of the
embryos are then implanted into the woman's uterus and then the remaining ones are stored
so that more attempts can be made if pregnancy does not result or if they desire more children
later when the couple achieves their desired number of pregnancies they're faced with the
choice of what to do with the remaining embryos they can choose to discard them and destroy them
they could donate them to other couples who are experiencing fertility problems or allow them
to be used in stem cell research stem cells can also be found in non-embrios or non-embriotic
tissues this includes in the umbilical cord of a newborn and in the primary teeth of
children adult stem cells have been found in a variety of organs and tissues including
in our bone marrow and in some blood vessels and muscles the brain and the liver the role
of stem cells in the adult body is to help maintain tissues and to replace damaged or
disease cells adult stem cell research has in some ways progressed more rapidly than expected
due to the right wide variety of tissues in which these cells can be found but it's been
hampered because these cells also occur in very small numbers in a particular tissue
and will divide only a limited number of times these properties make establishing useful cultures
of stem cells somewhat more difficult when using stem cells derived from adult tissues
versus those from embryos whether derived from embryos or from tissues of children and
adult stem cells can someday possibly be used to replace organs damage in accidents
or organs that are gradually failing due to degenerative diseases some of these diseases
are of the liver the long heart disease multiple sclerosis Alzheimer's and Parkinson's which
start with a slow breakdown of an organ and then progress eventually to organ failure
stem cells could provide healthy tissue to replace those tissues damaged by spinal cord
injuries or burns they could be used to produce healthy tissues as a replacement for damaged
tissues in a type of therapeutic cloning new heart muscle could be produced to replace
damaged heart muscle such as from a heart attack maybe someday a diabetic could be supplied
with a new pancreas and people suffering from some types of arthritis might get replacement
cartilage in order to cushion their joints thousands of people are waiting for organ transplants
and they might one day be saved by this therapeutic cloning done from stem cells if new organs
can be grown in the lab how do stem cells differ from skin cells well stem cells are
undifferentiated or unspecialized they can develop into skin cells but not vice versa
scientists who try to replace defective human genes with functional genes are performing
what's called gene therapy one type of gene therapy is called somatic cell gene therapy
and it can be performed on body cells to fix or replace the defective protein in only the
affected cells in this method scientists introduce a functional version of a defective gene into
the affected individual cell in the lab and it allows the cell to reproduce and then place
the copies of the cell bearing the corrected gene into the diseased person gene therapy
to date has focused on diseases caused by single genes for which defective cells can
be removed from the body treated and then reintroduced to the body for example there
are studies underway to determine whether individuals with genetically inherited lung
disease like cystic fibrosis can be able to breathe in harmless viruses carrying a functioning
copy of the cystic fibrosis gene if that gene gains access to long cells and replaces the
non-functional version of the functional one lung function could improve one additional
type of genetic engineering involves making an exact copy of an entire organism by a process
called reproductive cloning this process has proven to be very controversial for many especially
when the cloning involves humans cloning actually happens naturally in a woman's body when identical
twins are created they're basically human clones of each other this is when an embryo
subdivides into two separate embryos early on in development and then both go on to grow
into their own organism but because they came from the same sperm and egg they're genetically
identical many mammals have been cloned in the lab as well such as sheep cattle goats
pigs horse mice cats rabbits camels and monkeys the process for cloning whole organisms involves
nuclear transfer you start with an egg a nice healthy egg and you remove the nucleus from
it then you take a body cell or a somatic cell of the organism you want to clone and
you remove its nucleus and transplant that nucleus into the big empty egg then you subject
it to some procedures to make it start dividing without fertilization from a sperm and then
it grows into a zygote or an embryo then you implant it into a surrogate mother and
then the clone is born as an infant this process is currently used for animals and it's the
process that was used in the 1990's for the famous dolly the sheep of course there's some
ethical concerns that come with this it appears likely that the same nuclear transfer technique
can be used to clone humans possibly one day but ethical concerns have thus far prevented
this from happening if human cloning does occur it's not clear whether implanted embryos
can survive gestation to be born nor is it known what if any health issues there might
be for human clones such as with dolly the sheep she died of cancer at about what would
normally be midlife for that type of sheep that she was more studies obviously need
to be performed before something like this would be tried with humans but many different
animals have been cloned in the laboratory in this way initial attempts at cloning focused
on livestock that had genetic traits that would make them beneficial to farmers like sheep
that produced high quality wool were the very first cloned animals because the animals genome
is duplicated cloning prized livestock leaves less to chance than simply allowing two animals
to breed another thing to consider is that when you do clone something you might expect
it to have the same personality and temperament and intelligence and such as the original
but is that the truth we all know that there is of course nature but there is nurture as
well every organism has its own experiences as it grows up and matures which then gives
it different temperament different intelligence and different behaviors so which treatment
is used with cystic fibrosis patients remember it was somatic cell gene therapy what human
disease might be repaired by future CRISPR technology well we discussed hemophilia as
one of the examples make sure you look through all of the learning outcomes and make sure
you can do each of these return to the different parts of the lecture and the book and the notes
for anything that you still have questions on or would like to reveal